guys its Bob again your uncle Bob and we
have another episode of tea belly and um
last night I was gonna go see the movie
um the witch you know and my brother
we're gonna go and stuff and then Eric
Griffin who is on the workaholics and
he's also a friend of mine told me not
to see it and then um I regret not
seeing it why not to see it because yo
Dee goes yo dude it's like you know
there's it's artsy it's not it's not
good it's not scary I don't understand a
word they're saying but then I looked up
online some of the reviews and stuff I
regret not seeing it
he also said he hated Matt Matt he
didn't like Mad Max because there was
not enough I'm not kidding you he goes
it's not you know in post-apocalyptic
times you know women would be you know
what do you want it attacked so wait
you're trying there was enough Eric
Griffin wanted more women I'm not gonna
say the word but attacked I didn't say
nothing I know it's a nothing I he just
told me that in a post-apocalyptic
Olympic apocalyptic yes world that more
women will be attacked it doesn't make
any sense yeah there would be though
so you mean no but in I agree with them
in in in Mad Max um those women wouldn't
be able to do what they were doing with
the guns even the old ladies with the
guns at the end oh yeah yeah they'd be
in my dungeon would you do that opposed
no okay I'm just saying no no I really
have a very very strong like brutal
rebuttal to anything all the [ __ ]
that you just said or but I'm dealing I
have a lot of your cold yeah no I have a
fever
I have fever brain right now so I'm
going to just sit back and just absorb
all that [ __ ] that just spewed out
of your dirty mouth I didn't say
[ __ ] I'm just saying let's suppose
like you know like in the game I'm
playing right now fall out there was a
post-apocalyptic and I had a shotgun
right I'm just letting you know that I
would have a dungeon okay fYI fYI I
could operate any any rifle better than
you
have you said you've shotguns I'd keep
you in my dirty little dungeon that's
fine all right and you'd be in my
dungeon no you know I wouldn't be su
would there was no way you could capture
me tell me how you could capture me
interesting I would have a tranquilizer
gun right you don't you are blind by
then I would speak the Filipino language
behind a bush but I like to learn what
is that yeah my simple people yeah yeah
and then yeah right in the neck right
yeah and the next year no boys any way
to use what tranquilizer name one what I
yeah hyper burden Dermott needles yeah
when hypodermic needles with poisonous
side and anyway um you'd be tied up with
you Amy Adams Natalie Portman dude we
all down there tied up actresses and
kalila
yep I wouldn't do anything sexual I
would Chloe collection ly gonna clean
the collector yeah clean ah did you not
see Natalie Portman and V for Vendetta
yeah she would not be able to shave her
head and in my world he would destroy
you
that's that's your opinion but anyway I
was gonna watch The Wiz and that's an
opinion but in a post-apocalyptic world
you know me it's my world baby you're
right you get out of breath after ten
seconds of walking there is no English
you really think that I would work out
in that scenarios no multiple scenario
because it would happen out of nowhere
it would happen just you know like for
instance if it happened tomorrow you'd
be [ __ ] Bobby you're [ __ ]
why name one skill that you actually
have I can other than eating yeah but
you know you have to eat to live
what are you gonna plant you don't know
how to plant you don't know what seeds
are what I do you're gonna poison
yourself as far as you know you Gago get
a watermelon then take the seeds out of
the watermelon I plant those [ __ ] damn
yeah I'm gonna have a whole watermelon
farm you know I can survive on that
[ __ ] you'll have agent oh yeah cover
their heads you know yeah anyway um Eric
Griffin's wrong about movies and I'm
gonna watch the witch and um it's gonna
be good
okay and he was wrong about Mad Max it
was a good movie you know and then
Saturday I did a corporate I don't was a
corporate it was a birthday party yes
this guy Jeff he's a farmer and he has
lots of money and he said I want Bobby
Lee in the Dan ban to be at his party
and I showed up with Gilbert and my crew
with George and kalila to the road trip
to this Country Club in Bakersfield yeah
and I told Gilbert to go up and do five
minutes and what'd I tell you
I said get everyone because it was at a
nightclub looking oh my god I think it's
worse than a nightclub yeah so you guys
there was a stage in in front of an
empty dance floor yeah cuz everyone was
just on the sidelines drinking and
mingling yeah like as all with all
parties Gilbert to get everyone sitting
because that was your job bro there were
no seats on the empty day I sit on the
floor whatever bro you know I got them
all out what Bobby Lee might take
pictures with you boom everyone floods
yeah I like to way I do light away to
win and it was a [ __ ] nightmare that
cake would you say not your worst gig
though oh I've had a hundred that worst
case it's one of those situations where
you cannot tell a real joke everyone's
drunk everyone's there to mingle no one
is there to watch any type of real
comedy so they want you you either be
quick ones work reiterate that the
people were nice oh they were so now we
we had a good time it was just a
nightmare scenario for any comedian
because you couldn't tell joke so I went
I'll I got told what ten minutes of
jokes and in my head I'm like I don't
know if I can do my whole act here it
was that chaotic you planning to do a
lot of it I was trying to do it you know
but it was just like I was looking
around and I was like this is a
nightmare
yeah jokes that would normally destroy
it would be social stuff yet but I did
like one-liners one-liner one-liners the
only things that work and then what I
did was I just said [ __ ] it
I went on code you know me read what I
call it 9-1-1 now I went on Code Red you
were terrible oh yeah they're laughing
though if you're his job it really
helped because : George were laughing
their asses off so I was like let's just
hop together it was just so funny to
watch how awkward it was that George and
I were just laughing
but then I went up and I got Jeff on
stage I got completely naked into my
underwear I did a lap dance and then I
did photos and we ran out of there do
you feel bad about yourself when you do
that
no I do not you enjoy it listen I'm
getting there too paid to pay to
entertain I can went out there with my
best intentions with love in my heart
with God the Lord in my heart
[Music]